series and sequences series and
sequences is a really fun topic it's a
much like integration it's one of the
kinds of topics that actually explains a
lot of the results that you already come
to know from earlier years but we never
really had the pieces to explain why
they were the case so as we go through
this topic we're going to be able to see
I've some really interesting surprising
results even though the maths of it is
very very basic it can be it can yield
really interesting insights so let's
start by defining a few things and
introducing some terminology okay what
is a series or sequence it's probably
best to start with what's a set we
introduced sets are way back in u-ace
and the idea is set is it's just a
collection of numbers right we usually
indicate a boom with a set of curly
braces so a collection of numbers such
as say of the set of whole numbers right
or you know the set of counting numbers
babies for easy example so there's a set
of numbers right it's anything it could
be infinite as this one is set to the
dots indicate or it could be finite it
could be limited just a few numbers for
instance I can say the set of odd
numbers under 10 right so I could say no
that would be the set of numbers now
really important for you to get that
this set here would be equal to let's
just forget about the counting numbers
per second this set here would be equal
to this set nearly that order does it
matter in a set right it's just that
these phone numbers those have numbers
safe deal
okay they're equivalent now as we go
through a set a sequence add order right
and that's why we say figs are
sequential
right and that means all that matters
okay so sequence you can call it an
ordered set right okay so when you've
got some water here we ditch the curly
braces and we say well look specifically
the order that I'm interested in say for
the odd numbers I I could have them in
say a decreasing order right so this
order would be different you know that
sequence be different to this sequence
okay because I hear when I say which
sequence is which one's descending and
once ascending right the sequential the
sequence matters so if that's what a
sequences what's a series a series is
simply adding them all up right so a
series will be the sum of a sequence so
so essentially instead of commas in
between our terms here that's what we
call each individual thing each
individual value at home instead of
commas I'm going to have plus signs
that's all so that would be a series
right there okay
now sets sequences series the next
important thing that we need to get use
how do we talk about and describe these
kinds of sets of numbers how do we
describe it well the first thing is that
I've already mentioned we call each
individual number a term right so this
secret emlv sequences or have five terms
in them to be able to distinguish
between them we nail each term so for
instance this term would be turn one two
three and so on and as a short hair for
that
a term like say term 1 we would call it
t1 okay
so therefore turn 2 will be T 2 and so
on and if I want to describe a general
term say the inter where ends you know
an integer the answer we would call that
T mod M how it read it okay now that
target talk about each of the individual
terms how do i define the whole sequence
or the entire the whole series okay well
there are three ways are the first way
you've already seen actually we've shown
it here the first method is just to name
enough of the terms so that the pattern
becomes obvious right so name enough
terms to show a pattern and then
actually that's why I've been doing so
far okay
and that doesn't mean you have to name
all the terms just enough of them so
suppose I didn't want just the odd
numbers under 10 suppose I wanted the
odd numbers under 100 I might say 1 3 5
7 generally either three or four terms
is enough then I could say that I've
gone up to 97 now you know and that's
enough so no dot indicates just all feet
between terms that's enough to show the
pattern that's the first simplest way
but sometimes you don't have this kind
of information it has something a little
more general so here's our second method
for describing a sequence or a series
this is why this terminology is so
important you may have a general
algebraic expression for the in turn
okay so a general algebraic expression
okay so let's consider a simple example
first let's think about say the sequence
of even numbers the sequence of even
numbers so if I were to do it this way
maybe enough toast the shop had not just
say two four six suppose I want all the
even numbers I'm just going to go on
forever here now in this case I can see
well term 1 is 2 times 2 is 4 10 3 is 6
so what would the nth term be well
there's a really obvious path between M
the number of the term and the term
itself the term itself is just double
whatever number of the term amatsu right
so in this case I would say it's here
then generally speaking is equal to 2
where there's a general algebraic
expression which defines every single
term ok and you can modify that based on
whatever kind of sequence you've got or
you could come with all kinds of weird
sequences for instance if I said see M
equals N squared right you'd have or the
first term would be 1 squared the second
term would be 2 square the second term
would be 3 square and so on and we call
we actually want this again in your rate
these are some of the figures numbers
right these are the square numbers
obviously that's why it's squared right
so you can have a general algebraic
expression yeah this is just fine
there's one more way of defining each of
our terms in our sequence or series and
that's what we call a recursive
definition
what's a recursive definition our
recursion it determines familiar
problems anyone who's study software
design it means something that refers to
itself so you know like like a recurring
motif right that's that it was so how
does this work well let's consider say
this term this
series sequence stories the secrets of
your annulment the way a recursive
definition starts works is it tells you
it's not so the first term in our
sequence of even numbers that would be
to you and then comes the the recursive
part of the end term which depends on
the previous toes before right so as you
can see if I go to any term here I take
the third term one second to the water
fifteen term it's the previous term plus
two that's what makes it the even
numbers right so the third term is the
second term plus two and I guess that
would make the fifteenth term the
fourteenth ten plus two so if I want the
nth term the previous term would be n
minus one term okay and to get to the
next one I had to so you see why it's
called a recursive definition the
definition for one term depends on other
terms okay now you might say oh this is
a bit of an awkward way of defining a
sequence isn't this much simpler if for
instance you wanted the sequence of even
numbers that is probably true it is it
does look a little awkward however there
are some sequences that you can only
define this way and in fact one of those
famous sequences the human Archie
sequence which is that set of numbers
which often turns up in nature the
Fibonacci sequence it's very difficult
but it's not impossible
I require some imaginary numbers
actually but I it's not very easy to
define the Fibonacci sequence by the
general algebraic expression T of n is
equal to equal to what
okay you go look it up it's quite
interesting it's much easier though and
everyone learns it by a recursive
definition so how does it work well
let's just write out in the first way
how many patents we need to get the
patent of the Fibonacci sequence well
the first numbers are kind of arbitrary
right
decided to start at one you can start at
different numbers actually for use the
same rule you get different sequences
like the Lucas dove it that's another
topic anyway now you've got two numbers
how do you in the next one you add up
the previous two so that's why you go to
and then the previous two three then the
previous to give you five eight and
thirty and so on okay now like I said
looking at that sequence a general
algebraic expression doesn't pop out
very easily it's not like I can just
multiply myself numbers or just square
or cube or whatever how do we use a
recursive definition well again I said
we start with these two terms right we
really could start anywhere we like but
since we're starting one and one we say
turn one one turn two one now I can say
not just the third term but every term
after that sorry term Yeah right
what's it equal to the previous two
terms so the previous term is here and
before that okay now so far for all of
these like say we're talking about these
ends here right what we're actually
saying is that M is not just any number
like you can't have VR you know the one
and a half term or the by the pipe to
write with we're dealing with integers
here right
so I'm actually specified I'm not just
introduced for positive integers right
now here we're also talking about
positive just but being even more
specific you know and these are the set
houses but in addition to that for this
recursive definition to work and can't
have any value just any values that fit
this it can't be one for instance
because then you going to have the zero
term and the negative one negative first
term which we don't really have a
the series doesn't go backwards past
here okay so we'd say that this term
works after two right so it has to be
two so there's there's three ways to
define a sequence or series just bash
out a number of terms get a general
algebraic expression for each term
individually or use a total recursive
definition start somewhere and then
define a rule that tells you where to go
from there